[Applause]
hey everyone I'm ash crossing with
behind the screens like behind the
scenes this week it's all about Maze
Runner the death cure the finale the
final installment of The Maze Runner
franchise I know I was lucky enough to
attend the premiere and fan screening of
the movie in Los Angeles that's like a
dual thing there where fans were lined
up since 5 o'clock in the morning and
this was at night so I'm even sooner
just to see the cast and be a part of
this awesome night and let me tell you
they don't normally do these premieres
combined with fan screenings usually
they keep them separate so this was a
very special event you don't see too
often so the thing about The Maze Runner
franchise is and bear with me here
it's the underdog of these young adult
dystopian franchises when the first base
runner came out there was no guarantee
there would ever be another Maze Runner
movie the cast was even warned that and
almost anticipated that being the case
going in and what makes these movies so
special is that the fans carried the
series to the finish line and if I'm not
convincing you I talked to a few people
who might we wouldn't be here without
these guys it's you know we didn't it
wasn't a total sure thing that you know
our little movie I feel like that we
made five years ago would resonate with
so many other people outside of the
original book fans you know and so I
don't know it's just it's it seems like
it's just been I don't know we're just
so lucky you know it's it's they've
carried us through three movies they're
the reason we've gotten to do this so
it's great seems like you have quite a
few fans this is one of the loudest
premieres I've ever been to your guys
fans are so diehard I mean how would you
sum up this entire experience if you
could I mean the fans are everything we
wouldn't be able to do this without them
I mean they've supported us through this
whole journey when we thought we were
just a little movie that was shooting in
Baton Rouge Louisiana and now we're on
the third one the final one and they've
supported the books and they've
supported us as a cast and individually
and you know none of this would be
possible without them so that's why we
wanted to do this the third time the
final time
open it up to the fans allow them the
opportunity to just come and scream and
shout and do this it's lovely to see
such a turnout of appreciation towards
iMovie so it means the world I think
this final movie is our thank you to
them if it wasn't for them we wouldn't
be employed we wouldn't get to still
hang out with each other and create
these movies when we did the first one
we had no idea if it would go to a
second and Fox even said to us there's
no guarantee so to be here five years
later it's thanks to them it's been like
four or five years and to have these
these what's the word I'm looking for
dangerously passionate fans ear it's
been a tremendous blessing that's you
guys now as you probably already know
Dylan O'Brien our leading man was badly
injured on set in March 2016 Dylan
himself said the accident almost ended
his career and this delayed the movie
indefinitely for a while no one was
certain if the movie would be finished
or if Dylan himself would even want to
finish the movie but after a year of
recovery filming resumed in March 2017
and I had to ask him what that meant to
him and the cast to finish the movie for
me personally like that was the big home
obviously that was a really a big thing
to get past and hurdle and just to get
back and and complete it you know and it
really meant a lot to me to do it though
and I think it meant the world to all of
us especially after what happened to
just be able to finish it and not leave
it like that you know that would have
been a tragedy for how much this is all
meant to us you know so that must have
been healing for you as well yeah huge
oh yeah hugely hugely and we wanted to
finish it off in a great way and it
would have been such a shame to not get
to do that I think we were all
incredibly proud of Dylan for coming
back and wanting to finish it and we
kind of owed it to him to make it the
best movie possible that's so great Maze
Runner the death cure is out on Friday
are you guys excited what is one thing
from the book that you need to happen in
this movie is there anything you hope
they change maybe I don't know let us
know in the comments and if you log on
to that twitter.com you can tweet me I'm
at ash cross and let us know what movies
you were excited about and I'll talk
about them for you until next time